des ballons des bouteilles des sacs en
plastique c'est dans cette décharge
fictive que le franco cubain andy
cabreira villa voulait tenter son
nouveau record d'apnée ce dimanche 10
juin objectif dénoncer la pollution des
océans se glissant dans la peau d'un
mammifère marin qui a plus de 300
millions de tonnes des déchets les
plastiques dan sociaux donc c'est un
vide endossant déchets par minute ça à
dire tous ces centres déchets par
seconde
synchro là tout le monde est menacé
l'objectif est également sportif
l'apnéiste 46 ans doit réaliser au
minium trois cent soixante cinq
longueurs en trois ans reprenant sa
respiration tous les 25 mètres pas
facile quand les déchets flottent à la
surface serait très compliqué parce que
ça ralentit la nage et peut-être même
aller
parmi les sacs en plastique qui est bon
c'est un symbole et les méduses dans
laquelle les tortues ils mangent les
plastiques et pense que ça mais je suis
mort donc oui ça ralentit la nage mais
c'est pas grave c'est moi qui a décidé
que c'est comme ça dû au jeu le jeu est
bien sûr nous en dit cabreira ville a
finalement parcouru en trois heures 395
longueur l'équivalent de 9 875 km un
record pour la bonne cause qu'il
pourrait de nouveau amélioré dans les
prochains mois